je n'ai jamais la série je n'ai jamais
cédé je n'ai jamais baisser le regard et
c'est de cette façon là que nous avons
construit cette forte alors maintenant
avec ces mots jean luc mélenchon tend la
main à la nouvelle génération pour sa
dernière participation à l'élection
présidentielle et au cours d'une année
et demi de campagne l'insoumis a encore
su faire parler de lui et de son projet
visiblement pas assez pour se qualifier
au second tour puisque quatre cent vingt
mille voix ont fini par le distancer de
marine le pen une défaite de plus pour
le candidat qui croit tout de même dur
comme fer en l'avenir de son parti alors
la france a soumises résistera-t-elle à
jean luc mélenchon
réponse dans facture
on le disait depuis 2012 jean-luc
mélenchon a participé trois fois à
l'élection présidentielle pour sa
première candidature et sous le slogan
prenait le pouvoir qui récolte 11 10 %
des voix alors en 2012 il faut se
souvenir que jean luc mélenchon venait
de quitter le parti socialiste dans
lequel il a été adhérent de longues
années est déçu par le manque de
radicalité
jean luc mélenchon voulait créer une
force nouvelle plus populaires et
c'était tout l'enjeu de sa campagne de
2012 où il voulait parler à la gauche à
la vraie gauche la gauche populaire et
donc avec l'enjeu de concurrencer comme
ils le pouvaient françois hollande et
surtout inscrire les premiers pas pour
l'avenir en 2017 jean luc mélenchon
travaille son image
le parti de gauche devient la france
insoumise et le rouge très communiste de
2012 a laissé place à un ciel nuageux
marqué d'une nouvelle expression la
force du peuple une stratégie qui lui
permet d'être crédité de 19 points 58 %
des voix au premier tour juste derrière
marine le pen en 2022 même scénario jean
luc mélenchon termine en troisième
position derrière la candidate du
rassemblement national mais passent la
barre symbolique des 20% au premier tour
jean luc mélenchon en 2012 veut parler à
la gauche c'est son à sa colonne
vertébrale il va absolument apparaître
comme une alternative au parti
socialiste qui est pour lui un parti
effectivement de csp + de bourgeois
d'intellectuels lui veut reconnecter la
gauche avec le peuple et ce qu'ils
limitent finalement à 11 12 pour cent
parce qu'ils ne touchent pas le peuple
entièrement en 2017 il fait l inverse le
pari de toucher plus large de d'enlever
les drapeaux rouges dans ses meetings
pour les remplacer par des drapeaux bleu
blanc rouge ne plus vraiment parler du
terme de la gauche mais parler de la
france donc il ya vraiment un changement
de stratégie il est revenue sur cette
stratégie en 2022 en voulant parler au
peuple et finalement il a surtout la
toucher les quartiers populaires et les
catégories socioprofessionnelles
supérieures et donc il passe finalement
un petit peu à côté de ce monde rural
ouvriers en dix ans jean luc mélenchon a
fait de la france un soumises un parti
de gauche qui a vu son électorat
progressé notamment chez les jeunes
quand on regarde la composition de
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon on
observe de scrutin en scrutin au cours
des trois dernières élections
présidentielles des lignes de force qui
sont identiques d'abord pas de
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes un électorat qui s'est assez bien
équilibré de ce point de vue là un
électorat plutôt jeune et là jean luc
mélenchon a beaucoup progressé chez les
18 34 ans grandes catégories des jeunes
fait quasiment jeu égal avec marine le
pen donc ça c'est une des progressions
une des percées de jean luc mélenchon
lors de cette dernière élection
présidentielle de 2022 plus de
difficultés à séduire un électorat plus
âgé mais puis en termes de catégories
socioprofessionnelles
et bien il est largement distancé
marine le pen dans la catégorie des
ouvriers quasiment un rapport de 1 à 2
c'est un peu la même chose mais dans une
moindre mesure en ce qui concerne les
employés et puis c'est vrai que c'est un
électorat qui est composé en grande
partie de professions intermédiaires
hommes en colère en 2012 mauvais perdant
en 2017 et un bleu troisième en 2022
jean luc mélenchon a tout de même réussi
à élargir le socle électoral de la
france insoumise pour autant le parti
peut-il devenir hégémonique à gauche à
l'heure où le ps et les verts se sont
effondrés un premier élément de réponse
jean luc mélenchon à bénéficier de cet
effet de vote stratégique de manière
évidente c'est sans doute tous les
candidats celui qui en a le plus
bénéficié
50% de ses électeurs disent avoir voté
utile
c'est seulement 30
3 % pour l'ensemble des électeurs non
qu'on voit un vote utile très fort en
faveur de jean-luc loges la mobilisation
autour de jean-luc mélenchon et la
france insoumise pourrait être
trompeuses sur des élections plus
territorialisée le parti est largement
sous représentées les insoumis sont
absents effectivement dans de nombreux
territoires parce que tout simplement
ils n'ont ils ont un peu éviter
l'obstacle des élections municipales et
départementales des régionales ils se
sont toujours mis dans des alliances
parce qu'ils considéraient qu'il ne
ferait pas d'excellents résultats qu'il
fallait mieux se concentrer sur la
présidentielle que c'était pour la reine
des élections et que c'était de celle là
que tout découlerait ensuite les
élections législatives il espère faire
un bon score car ils pensent pouvoir
surfer sur la performance de jean luc
mélenchon à la présidentielle et il
considère que c'est une question
nationale que les françaises s'y
intéresseront peut-être plus que des
élections avec l'ombre plus locale parce
que il faut le noter la france insoumise
n'a aucun représentant au sénat
seulement 17 députés à l'assemblée
nationale 23 conseillers régionaux dans
cinq régions et une trentaine de mères
dans le pays les plus jeunes vont me
dire et bla on n'y a encore pas arrivé
j'ai pas loin
fait mieux d'une certaine manière c'est
pour lui la meilleure configuration
possible pour quitter tout cas pour se
mettre en retrait de la vie politique il
laisse un parti politique qui s'est
implantée dans la vie nationale depuis
depuis une quinzaine d'années qui est
une marque
il a su faire monter toute une
génération
il ya beaucoup de députés de la france
info biz qui sont de grande valeur et
qu'ils sont bien identifiés par par les
médias donc ça c'est une force aussi en
termes
d'incarnation après cette déclaration du
désormais ex chef des insoumis qui sera
désigné pour reprendre le flambeau il y
en a beaucoup aujourd'hui d'insoumis
potentiel qui aimerait finalement dans
quelques années cette incarnation de
cette gauche insoumise populaire
clémentine autain aimerait évidemment
représenté quelque chose elle avait
d'ailleurs fait un big bang de la gauche
il ya quelques années pour essayer de
recomposer déjà une gauche en mauvais
état il y a évidemment adrien cat-nat ce
qui est un peu le fils naturel jean luc
mélenchon c'est lui qui lui a donné les
clés saâd à lui qui lui a donné les clés
il ya quelques années pour reprendre la
france insoumise mais il y en a d'autres
il ya matile panneaux la députée une
députée insoumise aussi à qui il a donné
la présidence du groupe donc on voit que
jean luc mélenchon a placé un peu
partout des avec au stratégique et c'est
potentiel successeur et il nous confiait
il ya quelques semaines que la après ce
sera à eux de voir ils devront se mettre
d'accord ensemble et que c'est comme ça
c'est la vie ce sera à eux de décider la
réussite du parti des pendant que ses
fidèles et la marche sera haute pour
celui ou celle qui succédera à l'un des
plus grands orateurs de la vème
république